my name is Hari Kondabolu but I signed
my name hurry cake under Beaulieu
because as a child my mother told me to
keep my middle initial in my name in
case there was another Hari Kondabolu
there wouldn't be any confusion what I
find most upsetting about this is that
my mother assumed if there was another
Hari Kondabolu I would have to keep the
middle initial in my name I would be the
less famous Hari Kondabolu my mother
thought I was gonna be the Michael B
Jordan of Hari Kondabolu it's a summer
time people are excited about the summer
unfortunately I am NOT I do not like the
summer for personal reasons I have a lot
of white friends and I'm sick of them
talking about tanning even I gotta avoid
tan lines I'm not offended by this I
just have nothing to add to that
conversation I don't have your freak
mutant ability to change colors you're
like the shittiest x-men ever I love
chocolate my favorite kind of chocolate
in the world is Belgian chocolate but I
was thinking about it what makes it
Belgian exactly because the cocoa beans
come from West Africa and the sugar
comes from Latin America and Asia and I
don't know if you all know this but
cocoa beans and sugar do the heavy
lifting and chocolate so what parts
Belgian exactly is it this part I
Belgian Belgium has a rich stirring
history Belgium
Thanks
thank you if you wait long enough you
will clap after after a gig once this
guy comes up to me and he's like oh
hurry I like your joke but to play
devil's advocate you know without
Belgium it'd just be cocoa beans and
sugar so Belgium is pretty important in
the whole this is why you need to delete
your highschool friends from Facebook
people like that show up at the gigs
right first of all why do people have to
play devil's advocate it's basically a
phrase you could hide behind to say
whatever contrarian nonsense you want to
say while pretending you're being
objective when you generally just being
a dick more importantly why does the
devil need an advocate he is the devil
why does the Prince of Darkness need
your help exactly what are you telling
me is happening here is it like hey
Steve it's me the devil I need your help
right now
see that woman over there that saying
men and women should be paid equally in
the work force well I want you to tell
her on my behalf
that's not what's happening here also
why does the devil want you to make a
contrarian argument what does the devil
get out of a contrarian argument that's
somehow you play devil's advocate this
is how you play devil's advocate I think
men and women should be paid equally in
the work force that's interesting have
you thought about selling your soul to
the devil that's all the devil wants
that's all the devil has ever been
interested in
I think we should have universal
healthcare you know if you'd like to
live forever you could sell your soul to
the devil it's all the devil wants I
think we should make America great again
well oh you've already okay it's not
particularly a good time for immigrants
in this country I think about my parents
a lot what they've been through
especially my mom people saying things
like take that dot off your head or why
are you wearing bed sheets or why don't
you shut up and make me food and this is
just of me my brother said around the
house now can you imagine what for those
of you who groan my mom told me to tell
that joke so you can go to hell she
specifically said yes tell them you're a
piece of [ __ ] hurry tell them tell them
how disappointing you and your brother
are tell them of the terrible hand I've
been dealt due to patriarchy my mother
is the funniest person I know my mom is
the reason why I'm funny my dad's the
reason I have anxiety but my mom mom is
the reason why I'm funny so before I
leave tonight I want to read a few my
favorite mom jokes these are actual
things my mother has said to me so I go
up to my mom and I said hey mom sorry I
didn't call earlier this week and she
said it's okay it was a relief
then on the 4th of July I said happy
Independence Day mom
and she said thanks son but I lost my
independence 35 years to come
unrelated side note I am 35 years old
thank you very much everybody I'm
hurricane
[Applause]
you